one time I was in Paris and I walked
into this radio interview where this
[ __ ] radio DJ said I have a tattoo
artist here to tattoo you I am the great
Kawai you will get my initial the letter
C so I told him I really give a crap
about the letter C but I do want to get
a marijuana leaf tattooed on my wrist so
[ __ ] it
I'll get him both and that was why I
ended up with a pot leaf and the stupid
letter C on my wrist what wasn't long
before I was like why did I let that
[ __ ] make me his [ __ ] like that and
one night while we were filming jackass
number two I took a cigarette and just
put it out on the letter C and I did it
again and again all night it just burned
it and burned it until ultimately the
skin came off completely here it is
laying next to the big hole I burned in
my wrist well of course a few years
later I got clean and sober at which
point I didn't really want a pot leave
by my wrists anymore so I got the
ultimate cover-up tattoo where I turned
it into a palm tree with the sunset and
then later I added a photo of me surfing
which i think is totally rad and that is
the evolution of my wrist and the
do-it-yourself tattoo removal yeah